هل انت من عشاق كريستيانو رونالدو ام ترى
بان ميسي افضل السينما قد تساعدك في تحديد
رايك عبر سلسله من الافلام الوثائقيه
الشيقه التي تناولت جوانب خفيه في حياه
رموز كبار في لعبه كره القدم تعالوا معي
لنلقي الضوء على ابرزها في فيلم مارادونا
باي كوستاريكا يرافق المخرجه امير
كوستاريكا ايقونات كره القدم الارجنتيني
مارادونا في حوار يبتسم بالجراه والصدق
ويتناول اهم محطات حياته الشخصيه والمهنيه
حين تشاهد الفيلم ستجد نفسك امام لاعب
يتحدث في السياسه والنضال ضد الامبرياليه
الغربيه
ثقلا يتخطى حدود الملاعب والمباريات لذلك
لم يفترس محبوه لما واجهه في حياته من
متاعب واحداث مثيره للجدل لان ارثه وراسخ
ومحفور في ذاكرته
اما فيلم رونالدو فقدم للمشاهد نظره
حميميه عن اسطوره كره القدم البرتغاليه
عبر التركيز على حياته الشخصيه وعلاقته
بوالدته وابنه الصغير مع تسليط الضوء على
عزيمته التي لا تضاها واصراره على تخطي
حدود قدراته يتناول الفيلم ايضا مواجهه
رونالدو للعديد من التحديات المتتاليه من
ابرزها منافسته الشهيره والشديده
وبالحديث عن ميسي كثيراته الذاتيه لم تركز
على موهبته فحسب وانما كشفت للمشاهد
تفاصيل مؤلمه عن معاناته مع مرض نقص
هرمونات النمو والتحديات الهائله التي
واجهها في حياتها اضافه لذلك يعرض الفيلم
عددا من المقابلات الشيقه مع عمالقه كره
القدم الذين يتحدثون عمق عن مشوار ميسي
الرياضي الحافلي بالانجازات والارقام
الكرويه القياسيه التي حققها هذا الاسطوره
خلال مسيرته الاحترافيه فيما يصور لنا
فيلم زيدان
الاسلوب الانيقه والمتفرج لنجم الكره
الفرنسيه السابق زين الدين زيدان
وتحديدا خلال لقاء فريقه ريال مدريد امام
فياريال في الثالثه والعشرين من ابريل عام
2005 اذ تم اخراجه الفيلم باستخدام سبعه
عشره كاميرا لتصوير كل حركه يقوم بها
زيدان في تلك المباراه والتركيزي فقط على
مدى ذكائن داخل الملعب
وامكانياته المبهره في التحكم بالقرعه
واخيرا لا يمكن تجاوز فيلم
الذي قدم معالجه انسانيه صادقه عن واحد من
اساطير لعبه كره القدم بدا من نشاته في
احياء البرازيل الفقيره التي ثقلت مهاراته
مرورا بقياداتهم منتخب بلاده للفوز بكاس
العالم ثلاث مرات وصولا الى حضوره الاعلام
اللافته وشخصيته المحببه في كافه المحافل
الكرويدا من برايك هو اهم لاعب كره قدم في
العالم شاركوني بطريقه
[تصفيق]